the starting point should always be the
fact that Africans must take
responsibility for their own actions
Africans must take responsibility for
the problems of their fessing it's just
been 50 years since ganas independence
in 1957 there's been 27 years since the
independence of Zimbabwe there's been 13
years since the dependence of South
Africa so whatever is happening in
Africa we as Africans must take
responsibility for circumstances there
has been a major failure around vision
in Africa political vision and economic
vision there has been a major failure
around leadership political leadership
and economic leadership so Africans are
guilty as charged in terms of failure
having said that prior to our
independence and even after independence
there have been external factors that
have made our existence in our
development very problematical before
independence which doubled the slavery
and the slave triangle that distorted
the history and trajectory of Africa's
development after slavery does the
project of colonialism that again
disturbed and changed the history and
trajectory of Afghan development okay
and then we force wars in struggles of
independence and anti-colonialism we
managed to get our independence after
that independence these two were
elements of neocolonialism and external
factors external corporations external
governments that were involved in a leg
give way in our economic operations in
terms of manipulation of the economy
ownership of the industry's without
actually cultivating and building
infrastructure and so on and so forth
promoting civil wars Western powers were
involved in pitting one ethnic group
against another Western powers and
companies in Africa were involved I
involved in using ethnic conflicts to
get access to diamonds access to 0 and
so on and so forth so these are some of
the forces that have led to our
challenges in Africa slavery colonialism
neo colonialism and share grid and also
double standards hypocrisy and duplicity
in terms of foreign policy by the West
for example America we all love America
don't we but America in Africa supported
Mobutu's as a circle was a dictator in
zaira sorry America supported Savimbi
who was the red bow and the destructive
player in Africa they did that because
those characters were anti-communist and
they're serving the American agenda of
anti-soviet expansion so we don't blame
the Americans both Americans are
pursuing their own political litigators
but had a negative impact on our
development and also we were fighting
for independence the assistance we got
was from the east not west and so Soviet
Union China Cuba Gaddafi these
characters is despicable and some of
them are were very central in assisting
us in achieving our independence so
these are some of the forces and players
that have led to where Africa is today
but when the chips are down the buck
stops with the Africans because Japan
was wiped out during Second World War
but today Japan is
a global player they managed to fix
themselves up since 1945 but in Ghana
1957 to now we haven't done that in
Zimbabwe 27 years so we are not actually
scapegoating we're just analyzing the
factors but the bulk of the blame the
responsibility lies with us we're guilty
as charged as Africans but we're waking
up and we are working on making African
countries globally competitive through
science and technology and also
leveraging globalization we shall
overcome other subject